foreign
[Music]
good morning I'm Dr Kyle Pruitt of the
Yale child study center also member of
the Early Childhood peace Consortium and
we are inviting you to the second
discussion in the ecpc raising children
of Peace series
this is a natural topic for us to take
on we're in our 10th year we have been
growing and developing as a as an
organization
and it has become very clear to us that
the need for the
um the youthful voice
is essential to our being able to spread
the very important message about the
importance of Peace in early childhood
the generation represented on this panel
has taught us a great deal about this
concept nothing about me without me
and this is an organization of young
people and and a generation of young
people who have given a great deal of
thought to how their voice needs to be
in needs to be respected because of the
things that they have to say about the
way that the world is affecting them
very directly and this uh this
discussion is about this
intergenerational conversation which is
essential to enlarging our understanding
about the importance of Peace in the
early years
the um the group that you see in the
gallery will be introduced by Kyle King
who is a rising senior at Yale his
invitation to his colleagues has been
essential to making this conversation
even possible you will hear from each of
them he will introduce each of them in
turn we will then be joined by Aditi
shikande of the UNICEF at the end for a
conversation and Roundup Roundtable
Roundup of ideas and then we will finish
this morning's conversation with
thoughts about the future
uh Kyle King thank you the floor is
yours
thanks Kyle
um hello everybody my name is Kyle King
as Kyle Pruitt said I'm a rising senior
at Yale and I myself have been doing
advocacy work for about eight years now
primarily with two organizations the
international OCD foundation and UNICEF
um and before I go ahead and introduce
everyone else on this panel I wanted to
take a minute to share my own
experiences with advocacy
um and hopefully say something
interesting as I as I talk about my work
with those two organizations
um I started with the international OCD
Foundation or the icdf when I was 13
right after I finished treatment for my
own OCD I was diagnosed with that when I
was 12. and after a pretty grueling year
of treatment I thought if I could do
anything to help someone else with that
disorder I would do that um so I reached
out to the icdf I asked if I could be an
advocate and they said sure but then
they gave me no further instruction on
how to do that
my journey with UNICEF started two years
after when I was in ninth grade I was
walking up a staircase at the back of my
high school and I saw a poster of a boy
who's standing in the rubble of what was
his school
and here I was standing in my
well-funded public school in South
Florida and there he was standing in the
remains of his and I just was struck
with this thought that you know really
there's no difference between him and I
I just happened to be born here and he
happened to be born there and it felt so
unfair to me that that because of some
arbitrary Cosmic coin flip I had access
to all these resources and he didn't
um so I felt like I needed to do
something about that and I went and
joined my UNICEF club that day
and I've been doing work with both those
organizations for like eight years like
I said
um and I've gotten to see firsthand how
they interact with youth Advocates and
they've done it really differently
um and I think there's something to be
said and learned from the differences
that that this new organization shall
so starting with the icdf since I
started there first I um when I reached
out when I was 13 as I kind of alluded
to they provided me very little support
and very little guidance and they didn't
really tell me what I could or couldn't
do as an advocate they just said sure
you can be an advocate
um and I don't know if you remember when
you were 13 but I wasn't a terribly
confident 13 year old I didn't want to
talk to adults very much
um so for the first couple years I
really didn't do too much with the
irctdf because I I didn't really know
how to use my voice
my experience with UNICEF was really
different
when I was 15 and wanted to join and
start working with UNICEF I just went
and joined the club in my high school
um and that was a really easy way to get
started and and had there not been a
club at my high school UNICEF has full
web pages dedicated to helping kids
start a club in the United States and
even beyond the Klaus program UNICEF USA
has positions baked into their corporate
structure for youth advocates
so that's kind of the long way of saying
that UNICEF does what the iocdf didn't
which made it really easy for me to
begin my advocacy Journey with them and
as a result for the first couple years
of my advocacy work I mainly worked with
UNICEF
and as I kind of worked my way through
the different advocacy positions at
UNICEF I began to build up my voice and
I began to become a lot more confident
as an advocate and consequently I I
began to have more ideas and really want
to implement them more strongly and
that's when I began to realize that the
the structure that UNICEF had laid out
for me and that the iocdf hadn't was a
bit of a double-edged sword because over
the years there's been a lot of times at
UNICEF where the structure
began to feel a bit confining and I
began to feel boxed in and I felt like I
couldn't really use my voice as
authentically as I wanted to
so looking back at the icdf that that
experience was totally different because
after I had kind of found my voice at
UNICEF
the the lack of structure and the laws I
Fair governance over there
began to feel like a huge asset I I
could do the projects that I wanted to
do as authentically as I wanted to do
them and I would try certain things and
sometimes they would fail and sometimes
they would be great successes but it was
really incentivizing that I was able to
do the advocacy work that I really truly
wanted to do
and I don't mean to disparage either
organization they both meant a lot to me
as I've been growing up um and they both
taught me a lot of really important
things but one thing that I wanted to
communicate to all of you as you look to
engage youth in whatever organization
you're representing here
it's it's necessary to meet youth where
they're at because before a young person
finds their voice and when they're
getting started in advocacy it's really
daunting it's a really scary experience
and it's really important to have those
easy to get into positions like UNICEF
did to to help them along their way and
help them find that voice
but once they find that voice
it's it's really important to to
genuinely and earnestly hear that voice
out and allow a young person to express
their voice less they might lose it
entirely
okay that's a lot from me
um the two Kyle's I've spoken too much
it's time to pass it on to the other
youth Advocates on the call just by way
of context
um we all met me and the other three
young youth Advocates at an event that
was hosted by UNICEF last September in
New York
um we didn't know each other prior to
getting to New York and then we met in
New York and we spent three days
together and in those three days we grew
so close that I could oh I don't know
ask them to participate on a webinar on
a whim um which I think is pretty cool
that we we became such good friends so
quickly and I think it's because we all
have a lot in common
um so without further Ado the the first
youth Advocate who will be speaking
today is Penelope Leia Penelope's a
climate Justice Advocate primarily from
Norway
um and she's one of the most
accomplished Advocates I've ever had the
pleasure of meeting in my life and she's
also one of the sweetest people in the
world
um and I think uh you'll learn a lot
from her so Penelope
it's your time shine
thank you so much Kyle and thank you for
your talk thank you for having me
I started my activism when I was eight I
started because I was and I still am
sick and tired of violence and
inequalities and the fight for climate
Justice the fight for climate action is
the fight against these very forces
before I started my activism I
experienced violence in close relations
and this experience actually became my
entry into climate activism it fueled my
need to speak up and it strengthened my
impatience in the fight for a peaceful
and safe future for everything I love
the people the nature and life itself
and these impatience of mine has only
grown since then
as we know climate nature changes are an
amplifier of all other crises we face as
human beings the glamor nature crisis is
inevitably linked to the world's
security situation to economics and
poverty it's tightly linked to how we
understand ourselves and our own history
and of course to every single one of the
human and children's rights
I believe to understand it another way
is naive
therefore as climate Justice activists
I've found myself working with several
of these issues over the past 10 years
and in this talk I want to share some of
my experiences with you
but first I would love to mention some
background on the conversation around
climate and nature in my home country to
give you a better idea of how it is to
be a camera activist here
I believe I can safely say that the
debate around climate and nature changes
is the most polarized and heated but
there is in Norway
Norway is a small country with the five
and a half million people in 1969 we
found all oil and gas and since then we
have built our whole economy on oil and
gas production and expulsion
just before the summer holiday 19 new
oil licenses were approved by our
government
and there is currently no political
party that stands a chance of forming a
government that wants to stop giving out
new oil licenses and move away from
fossil fuel dependency fast enough
in 33 years our government has only cut
our Arena's class emissions by 4.7
percent
we are one of the countries in Europe
with the most climate deniers
one in four people in Norway don't
believe that climate change is caused by
human actions
there is no excuse for no rate to delay
change we have the solutions the
resources the possibilities the peace
and the people in power have had the
time
we keep on living with and enjoying the
freedoms people before us are fought for
democracies weekends eight hour work
days they did it for us
and still we seem to think that it is
impossible to change the systems we live
in
to me that is double standard we can
change what with U.S political
impossible
but to be able to create a better world
and to make people aware that it is in
fact possible to change it's been proven
that we need the voices of young people
and we need to ease the struggles young
people face in their advocacy for basic
human rights so now I want to share some
struggles with you me and my friends
from space in our work
we often talk about how young people
need to speak truth to power but we
rarely talk about what happens when
power speaks to you the hate you might
receive
a lot of activists lives in places where
it's not safe to speak your mind or be
politically engaged and even the ones of
us that live in safety can be unsafe at
some point
we need to hear the voices of these
activists we need to hear the voices of
activists from the Frontline communities
we desperately need that representation
but we have to make sure that these
spaces are safe for young people to be
represented in not just at the stage but
afterwards
you need to follow up and make sure to
the best of your abilities that they
have the support and safety that they
need
one of the ways to do this I believe is
to build more political organizations
for young children community
when I was younger it felt life
important to be able to use my voice and
get hurt for me it was a question
question of all or nothing I needed to
use my voice and feel like I had the say
in my own life and my own future I
needed to contribute
but when you're young it's often very
difficult to find organizations where
you can do just that where you're not
just questioned because of your age but
brought up and valued where everyone
understands that your thoughts are your
own and filled with as much Integrity as
if you were older
I started my activism in an organization
like this but we need help building more
of them
Youth Organization and frontlines
communities needs funding
the money is not going where it's needed
it's in the hands of huge companies and
businesses serving exploitive systems
gaining the very few but not with young
change makers or the Frontline
communities fighting for a better world
and we need to change the conversation
around funding as well
too often my friends and I are met with
huge skepticism when we advocate for
climate Finance or funding of Youth
advocacy communities
but one needs some level of Financial
Security to be able to work for other
freedoms
at the UN General Assembly Priyanka
Dominique Kyle and I repeatedly heard
the statement if you don't have a chair
at the table bring your own
that is not possible
if you're not invited and you don't have
the resources it is is of course not
possible to grab your own chair at the
table
and it's not just about having a chair
at the table but having a role at the
table getting opportunities to speak
talk follow the negotiations actively
ask questions
we need to talk about the conversation
the connection between human rights and
children's rights peace security and
climate change
and a lot of young people in the climate
movement wants to talk about these
connections because it's crucial to
understand to be able to implement the
just Solutions and have the just from
this transition we need
but if it is of course at viewpoints
it's seldom it's it's hard to get
through the media so we need help from
every one of you to bring this
conversation forward so we can move
forward in the fight for climate Justice
I believe activism is in its greatest
form peace building in its nature
we might never know which of our actions
may lead to change or may make more
people follow in our footsteps
therefore everything we do may turn out
to be important
when I hear myself speak now I realize
that a lot of points I have have to do
with building safety for young people in
one way or another
I believe to be able to build peace in
any form you need safety peace isn't my
experience not always peaceful but you
need safety to be able to fight for it
thank you
thank you Penelope that was incredible
um and when you mentioned that phrase um
like if there's no seed at the table or
bring your own share
um that I remember hearing that phrase
so often that it became somewhat Hollow
um
because yeah like like you said in my
experience it's not always as simple as
just bringing a chair and a lot of times
there are people at the table who don't
want to hear from a young person um even
if you get there in the first place
our next speaker is um Dominique
overiano which I hope I pronounced
correctly
um and she's a young Advocate from
Romania when Kyle asked me what
Advocates I I'd want to have on this
panel I immediately thought of Dominique
because
I've met a lot of Advocates through the
years and I don't know if I've met
anyone else whose emotion and like
robbed passion for the subjects that
they Advocate on is as evident as it is
when Dominique speaks
um they're really special and and
I'm really excited for this talk
hi thank you so much Kyle this is so oh
that was such a nice introduction I
wasn't expecting definitely no pressure
on me to deliver that emotion so I'm
very grateful to be here with all of you
I'm so grateful for Penelope for sharing
her experience before me because a lot
of the things that she has touched upon
also will find themselves throughout my
uh my talk as well so when I was first
invited here the first question that
popped into my head was what is peace
because we we hear this word everywhere
and it's it's on TV all the time here at
high level dialogues at school so in
preparation for the talk and for my
speech I asked the children that I work
with how do they Define the concept what
is peace for them and I observe that as
their age got higher their responses
were more complicated right they were
sprinkling this according to this
academic paper or it's actually hard to
Define and it was and less of their
answers came from their souls and too
many from the external forces that they
have have interacted with
um so one very very interesting
definition that I heard and it was from
um uh from one of my my colleagues that
is 10 was that uh peace is the
possibility to play without fear
and it was very important because many
children trade their childhoods to fight
because the problems are so so pressing
so fear fear is one of the worst
motivators but it is one that brings
children to advocacy be it fear of not
being accepted to fear of being killed
and upon hearing the word fear I
immediately thought about resilience
how many times did we as youth Advocates
hear that we are resilient how many
times did you as an adult hear it and
resilience has become code word for
silence you're so resilient because you
can take Injustice so easily you you
absorb it and you don't make a sound you
don't express the the grief you feel the
worthlessness the exhaustion because you
can take it
and this upholds the idea of
individuality like you are the soul
responsible for your mood
and it is through this that we allow
each other to rid of the collective duty
of protecting one another it is this
that becomes an obstacle to
intergenerational communication to peace
because peace means taking care of each
other
now to understand how you'd Advocates uh
how to help you to Advocates you must
understand their journey and while what
I'm about to to talk about might not be
an Universal account uh since everybody
has a unique in unique way it is based
on my experience and on those of the
people that I truly love
I truly believe that there are three
feelings that you encounter at all times
in your activist path one is Rage the
other is loneliness coupled with
belonging which I name as uh the feeling
of in-betwiness and then there's hope
these coexist at any time during your
path they don't uh alchemize from one
into the other day uplift each other
they spring from one another
so let's start with rage
I often felt that my country was at war
with me that it's hatefulness for
dissenting bodies peers through my soul
and it extracted all the all the light
and the love I was desperately trying to
Harbor
so determined to banish me from
contesting their hegemonic practices uh
different systems like nationalism
capitalism heteronormativity invaded the
minds of others my teachers my
colleagues my friends
isolating me from those I was fighting
for and it is not easy to care for a
community that seeks to destroy your
will and agency and to convince you of
your worthlessness because this
oppressive systems seeping through the
minds of those we love show up as
Penelope said as immutable their power
impossible to contest without a movement
so with this in mind in the universe
amusing Arrangements Architects sat down
created a city at the intersection of
the public and the private and asked the
vital question what if we put together
people broken by the same systems and
just let them love each other
so in a room with a circular table on
the third floor of a building in the
city of Fort Lee a group of students
from different parts of the world and
their Professor met every day to discuss
Theory as a way of survival
all having been hated by their countries
at a point in their lives or aching for
connection and understanding they
explore the musings of those in history
who share their struggles
unintentionally creating a
transgenerational knowledge hub
this is how you build a movement you
bring the outcasts the thinkers the
Believers the reformers the
revolutionaries those who want to
rebuild the systems that are hurting
them and you make them a safe haven and
in this place of safety you let them
Revolt you conspire with them you make
plans you organize you let them discover
their identity
I remember the immense rightful rage
that I felt when in my freshman year of
high school my colleagues my lgbtq
colleagues came to me and told me that
we can't keep each other from dying as
they were building their own networks of
care in absence of of already of support
from from our teachers because what else
can you feel when your planet is on fire
or when you get denied life-saving
procedures or when you are outed and
marginalized what are you supposed to
feel if not rage
we encounter fairness unfairness at
different times in our life
but the first feeling is that we are
alone in this hurt that we are the first
to experience this there is this is
where intergenerational support comes in
visibility is everything as you discover
people who think like you and who for
decades have been involved in the same
activism
activism is a love story beyond the
anger there is a group a movement a
collective to which you belong and with
which you fight and in the darkest of
nights when you're defeated it is the
people that become your fuel the
solidarity and support you're overcome
with when you're in tears and at the
brink of giving up you look up to them
and they reassure you that they fought
through worse times and that you have
the the tools and the foundation to
fight whatever your enemy is but above
all you have the promise of no matter
what no matter what happens
intergenerational support has your back
in this spaces of safety you learn to
choose Joy over Doom you're free to play
you construct the Safe Haven of Peace
this man-made circle of unity and then
you take it outside to the real world
soon enough you become a safe space for
others the peace inside of yourself
reflects outwards while you constantly
wonder what really is the impact you're
making your caretaker will sit you down
and tell you I don't understand this
issue you're advocating for yet but I'm
willing to learn your friend will ask
you to go to a protest together your
teacher will sign your petition the
youth you encounter will ask you how to
get involved you will become a catalyzer
a unifier an antidote
all we really want is youth is to be
safe to be understood to see our loved
ones and caretakers enjoy safety as well
now for this to happen adults need to
decenter themselves to come into our
communities to bring the power table
that we've been talking about before
into our communities and let us work
together instead of against each other
while safety continues to be seen in
securitization terms like countries
borders National Spirit we must remember
that these are abstract Concepts but
people are real
feelings are real
when we try to Define peace perhaps we
should ask ourselves how peace feels
rather than what it means
so I want to leave you with a question
before I end how does peel peace feel to
you and I'll start
for me peace feels like relief
it feels like taking a breath after
holding it for so long because finally
in the dark room that you thought you
were in uh and that your country with my
country was desperately trying to put me
in at the beginning of the story
there suddenly are people's hands to
hold light garlands and a lot of Hope
that was it back to you Kyle yeah
Dominique you
you more than lived up to the
introduction I gave you then
um
that's I'm reflecting on the question
what does peace feel like that's a
complicated question to answer I think I
would say like ease in a way I'm
thinking of my own experiences
um being marginalized for having a
mental disorder and
walking into a place and not being
marginalized for that felt feels like
ease to me um but I'd have to think
about it further our third youth
Advocate is Priyanka Lala she's an
advocate from Trinidad and Tobago
um and just a cool part of her biography
that I want to highlight before she
speaks is that she is an author and an
illustrator in a of a book called as far
as Ocean Adventure that she published in
um and I feel like it's a little unfair
that someone has like that much talent
like they can draw and they can write I
don't know it just kind of made me mad
um but Priyanka the floor is yours
thank you so much good morning everyone
and thank you for having me Cal's story
resonates with me because when I was
about six years old when I saw a young
boy about eight years old selling
vegetables with his parents I told my
grandfather that I wanted to be his
friend I felt that if we knew each other
he would I he would live my same life
and growing up in a small island he has
allowed me has allowed me to have a
close look at the world around me it's
given me
um an incredibly unique and invaluable
appreciation for nature and therefore a
passion to protect it the beauty of my
Island was mine to explore and cherish
and this is truly where my advocacy
began in 2017 at the age of 10 I came to
the realization that this Narrative of
protecting and preserving the
environment was not practiced by most of
our region evidence of dumping was
discovered in the mount mountains of
debris and pollution washed up after the
devastating hurricanes Irma and Maria I
felt compelled to take action and I knew
that if I wanted to see change I could
not go around asking others to change I
needed to start on my own and I needed
to lead by example to mitigate the risks
of my country and regions peace and
security
mind focusing began with education I
believe that our school curriculums did
not sufficiently address climate and
environmental issues and certainly there
was little focus on meaningful
sustainability our economy similar to
Penelope is based on oil and gas and we
have little attempts at diversification
to ensure a regenerative economy young
people need more opportunities to thrive
and this has led to brain drain over the
years
this is a threat to our country's peace
I decided that I would be the change I
wanted to see to build a more
sustainable country and a more
sustainable region
and this inspired my blog zero waste
living I learned a great deal for my
grandparents who live sustainably
because they learned from their parents
and that influenced the way in which my
family already lived I guess we can say
this is an example of intergenerational
Education that was happening in my home
and this quest for sustainability led to
the creation of the zero waste lunchbox
an initiative that I started at my
school I encouraged students to pack a
lunch with no disposables or plastic and
my dream was that one day this would
become a caribbean-wide initiative I
simultaneously created a zero waste blog
I researched and wrote about how we can
make almost every aspect of Our Lives
more sustainable and I realized that
meaningful climate action was not
difficult for my small island we did not
need to reinvent the wheel because the
solutions already existed as just a few
decades ago our grandparents were living
sustainably
when I became a national child rights
master I found a connection between
climate change and every aspect of child
rights and human rights but what stood
out to me the most was that along with
child rights came responsibilities we
have the right a healthy and safe and
thriving environment but it is our
responsibility to maintain and ensure
that for ourselves and for future
Generations
and after around four years of
consistent advocacy young people started
to contact me asking me what gave me the
courage to do this or how they could get
involved
and it became so clear to me that there
was an audience of young people out
there but they lacked the opportunities
and the support they needed to realize
their true potential
and one of my successes was becoming a
UNICEF youth Advocate where I was able
to meet young enthusiastic people like
Kyle Penelope and Dominique who truly
are passionate about their cause and
working with UNICEF and its Partners has
helped me to learn more about the
climate crisis and how every aspect of
Our Lives is affected by it I would say
that one of my biggest accomplishments
is my participation in the regional
consultation for Latin America and the
Caribbean on drafting drafting the
general observation number 26 on
children's rights and the environment
with a special focus on climate change
and after this conference my
eight-year-old sisters Vara and I wrote
and Illustrated and published zvaris
Ocean Adventures our objective was truly
climate education engaging empowering
and inspiring climate education giving
children the solutions that they could
Implement even at such a young age
but I still believe that we have an
uphill battle in small island developing
States we are still faced with the
issues of General disconnect between
real climate action and what is being
taught in schools and local programs
climate and environmental issues are
taught in science class without any
reference to how we are contributors on
a daily basis
many young people continue to use
single-use Plastics and are often
encouraged to start beach cleanups
however they do not realize that they
are contributing to the problems what is
required is not cleaning up every time
but a reduction but in short term and
ultimately a ban of these items and
environmental laws to be enforced
it is our Peril if this is ignored our
vulnerability is always evident when we
are hit by natural disasters entire
communities are destroyed causing
children to be taken out of school to
support their families and when they are
taken out of the education system they
are forced into child labor child
marriages and due to less income they
are usually left with poor nutrition and
no way out of this cycle
our Rising crime rate food insecurity
increasing figures in non-communicable
diseases an urgent need to for
transformative education are some of the
factors that jeopardize Regional peace
people fail to make these connections
between the reality and the climate
crisis which we feel and see the
implications of every day
we cannot have sustainable development
and peace under these circumstances and
while I have seen a growing number of
young people joining the conversation or
taking action in small ways it is not
enough in a country with 1.4 million
people the numbers in the conversation
are very small a few hundred may be
I also question the quality of
involvement as sometimes young people
invited as what appears to be tokenism
for photo ops on preparations of reports
for funding agencies and plans for
Meaningful long-term engagement seem to
be theoretical
I truly believe in intergenerational
action where we must work collectively
and in harmony to create affordable
accessible and sustainable education
systems with capacity building
opportunities and programs for young
people to truly be engaged and to know
that they have a right to have
meaningful seat at the table but there's
always hope thank you
that was also just an incredible speech
um
I was just reflecting again on the the
seat on the seat at the table and the
the issue of tokenization that you
brought up because I felt that multiple
times through my advocacy um just
feeling like I was invited to an event
um someone took a picture of me and that
picture ended up on a PDF on online
somewhere um but I didn't really get to
say anything at the event other than
just
cheese
um Kyle prude the floor is yours
thank you Kyle um
I'm writing down pearls as fast as I can
I feel very privileged to be sitting
here with this remarkable group of of
young people
I'm struck by their passion their
impatience of their problem the the
problems at the table uh that they so
accurately highlight this conversation
is a I hope an antidote to that problem
at the table
the um the hope that I believe Dominic
spoke about reminded me uh I believe
Bill McKibben the the very active uh
climate activist
um talked about hope as a verb with its
sleeves rolled up
and each of you have talked about action
passion your competence is very obvious
and we are looking forward to hearing
not only more from you but we're we're
now going to have the treat of listening
to Aditi shrikhande who is the early
childhood development program officer
from UNICEF and Aditi has the delightful
task of summarizing some of the things
that she has learned I hope she is as
perturbed as I am by the wonderful
things that you have brought to our
table today Aditi
thank you Kyle yes I do want to Echo
exactly what you've just said this has
been
so fascinating and I really appreciated
learning from each of the experiences
that you've shared so big thank you to
to all of our presenters today
um and I think some of the things that
you spoke about really caught on to a
lot of the key themes that uh UNICEF as
well we try to incorporate into peace
building things like Community
leadership and Community engagement
um mental health and well-being and
empowering young people to be leaders
and supporting their organizations and
initiatives I think these were all
things that I heard from all of you and
at the heart of unicef's Peace building
work this is what we strive to to do as
well
um to take a child-centered social
services approach uh and to Bridge
Community uh an intergenerational
divides to reduce social tension and
address the root cause of conflict which
I think some of you also mentioned so
there is a lot of alignment there and I
appreciated
um hearing that from a
less theoretical jargon-filled way and
more applicable
uh to to people who are living their
lives every day so it was great to have
that that framing
um I said a life course approach is what
UNICEF takes and um again I think this
is something that I heard from many of
you
um particularly Priyanka noted that you
say you mentioned uh Solutions
um for age-appropriate solutions that
that children could take to participate
um and I I really like that you brought
up that point uh so as Kyle Perot
mentioned my background is in early
childhood development
um and we believe that peace starts
early right from birth children are
interacting with the world around them
and they're developing critical skills
emotional regulation empathy uh social
skills and there are two really key
moments for building these cognitive and
socialization skills and one of those is
Early Childhood so which would be
roughly the ages of zero to eight and
the other is in adolescence which is I
think we heard many of our presenters
today started their Journeys around that
time which is incredible
um so these periods of time particularly
in early childhood is when children are
learning attitudes and behaviors towards
the other
um and in resource resource poor
contexts the access to services that
promote early childhood development can
also act as social equalizers so they
can help with breaking cycles of
inequities and Injustice
um making individuals and societies more
resilient to stress
um Dominique I noted your point on the
use of the word resilience and I I love
that you brought that up so when I say
resilience now I mean a communal
societal resilience rather than an
individual Let's Pretend everything is
okay
um and I I really appreciated that you
you unpacked that
um
so UNICEF has recently come out with a
new vision for early childhood
development which explicitly recognizes
the symbiotic relationship between peace
building and fulfilling children's
rights particularly their right to
development
um and of course this applies to working
with young people as well um unicef's
mandate goes up to 18 but of course we
recognize the fundamental role that uh
anywhere people from adolescence to
um young people whatever that that
category looks different according to
whichever theoretical framework you're
looking at but essentially
we we know the activists were speaking
about
um and
they there is an underlying
trust in the fact that
uh
youth play a really catalytic role in
building peace and therefore the work
that UNICEF tries to do is to teach
peace building and resolution skills
conflict resolution skills
um to support those youth-led
initiatives that we've heard about today
at a community level and at wider levels
as well and to really strengthen the
participation the meaningful
participation of young people in
National dialogues and decision making
and peace building processes I think
it's a fairly
common
um
common complaint really that tokenism
sort of takes over
um
rather than actual meaningful
participation so I I do believe that
that's one of the things that UNICEF is
trying to work on as well and I
appreciated that our presenters spoke
more to that
um
I think I
what I found really motivating about
what all of you uh spoke about today was
the way that you reframed these topics I
think very often topics particularly
those
associated with young people tend to be
de-politicized and I appreciate you that
you reframe that you politicized it and
you made that clear connection to peace
um actually I think there was a
particular uh
yes
sorry
um
Penelope you you mentioned you never
know which actions lead to peace uh and
I I think that that is
something that becomes very true
um particularly in
defining peace right this is again a
topic that was spoken too
um so you know we've had things like
climate change are slowly but surely
becoming political but not necessarily
things like sustainable initiatives like
those that you've told us about Priyanka
that you started or mental health or
Community or I I believe there was a
phrase
um uh dominicus the networks of care and
all of these being highlighted as
efforts and acts of Peace building
um is what I I truly appreciated that
all of the presenters brought uh to to
the floor today uh Aditi could I
interrupt for just a second please and
and as you were talking about networks
of care I want to remind people that
their questions are welcome in the chat
we will be monitoring those and after
Aditi has completed her comments we will
address the the questions that you would
like addressed not only to the
presenters but to a DT as well so
speaking of networks of care you are all
a part of it thank you very much go
ahead sorry to interrupt no no worries
it was actually great timing I was just
about to uh
what move into the discussion portion
um
so I I noted from many of you
um that you mentioned the lack of
meaningful participation
um or the opportunities for that
participation and I think something that
we've seen through research is that
young people
research and of course hearing from
experiences uh young people often create
their own spaces for expression and
building community and Leadership and
for example using digital platforms
online advocacy and I am just wondering
have any of you encountered the need to
find your own space in the same way and
if so what did that look like in your
experience
and over to anyone who would like to
respond to that
you can go first maybe and I think that
is what activism is about and you mean I
constantly shared search for new ways
new peaceful and Democratic devices I
can use in order to contribute to the
changes we need to see
um and a lot of these things are spaces
we make ourselves you know and and
Friends of future movement
internationally and nationally in my
home country is a great example of this
I believe and millions of young people
going out into the streets building our
own platforms and strengthening each
other in our work and so that is just
one example of like many things and many
many times we've built our own
communities to build our own places yeah
I think that's the core of being an
activist
thank you Penelope
um did any of our other presenters want
to speak to this
um I'd just like to add on to what
Penelope said in my personal experience
one of my first initiatives was my zero
waste blog and I started blogging
because it's a tool that I learned how
to use in school and I felt that you
know social media and the digital
display spaces where our generation is
it's where we spend most of our time and
it was how I could engage with my peers
and other young people in the Caribbean
and I started blogging about zero waste
not only to engage with young people but
also their parents and their Guardians
and being able to create something more
personal and unique to our circumstances
how can we Implement these sustainable
habits into our households our school
curriculums our communities to make it a
caribbean-wide initiative and something
that's easy and affordable to implement
and social media and my Sierra waste
blog was the perfect Avenue to achieve
this because of its reach and its
connect to the team
thank you Priyanka
um and I want to appreciate as well that
you said the reach of the blog that you
have also had were an active part of
creating that reach and I think that
that needs to be acknowledged
um Kyle or Dominique did you want to
come in as well
yeah I wanted yeah sure because I feel
like especially locally uh physical safe
space was always created uh by the
community right Children and Youth
Advocates have created their own
additional spaces inside their schools
if they never felt safe there or outside
of schools and adding on to what
Priyanka said about the digital space I
think that the digital space has brought
a component of transnationality to youth
Advocates organizing right you have you
find somebody in a different country
that has the same problems as you and
together you create this transnational
space of solidarity uh and and from
there you you of course have lovely
initiatives like the one we are
participating in today right because
Kyle reached out to us digitally and now
we're all here from different parts of
the words of a world so uh yeah I think
that constructing your own space as an
activist is like Penelope said one of
the core
um one of the core components of
advocacy
I also like have experience I guess
making my own spaces um I started like a
support groups for young people
um or Community groups for young people
with OCD and stuff like that
um but the challenge is like remaining
in silos of just young people doesn't
get the job done all the time um and
it's important to have conversations
like these where we interact across
generations and with people who are
in I guess higher up positions
um to make more systems level change and
I also you mentioned tokenization at the
very beginning of this question
um and I
the one one point about kind of like
tokenizing or having Youth kind of at
events and and maybe not knowing if
you're engaging in tokenization or not
um I've felt tokenized as different
events within UNICEF for the
international OCD foundation and
when that's happened I've I've I felt
you know angry at times um but it's even
though I was tokenized it felt nice to
be there um and it gave me a lot of
confidence being in those spaces and
even if maybe people didn't respect me
that time or didn't like listen to what
I said that time being there
made me feel like my voice mattered a
little more than it did before and then
the next time I was there I was able to
talk a little louder and maybe they
didn't hear me that time but then the
next time I was able to talk a little
louder
um so
I guess if if someone is scared that
they might be engaging in tokenization
invite youth anyway
um because in my experiences only helped
me get a little bit closer to being
heard
thank you Kyle and I appreciated the
Practical solution there as well um
that's a great way to think about it
um I would love to be able to open this
up to the Q a at the moment I don't see
anything in the Q a box but if anyone in
the audience has a question for our
presenters please do add it in to there
um and while we're waiting for those to
come in I'm just going to monopolize
your time some more because I find you
very interesting
um and I think actually many of the
things that you said lead me into this
next question this idea that
creating these owns your own spaces is
fundamental to activism and
the idea that you grow as activists
um I think our
barely newish ideas for for many of us I
mean
some of you are speaking about activism
from when you were younger I remember
when I attempted activism at the age of
10 there were there were no options for
digital participation or creating my own
space in that same way so I'm wondering
you have been in this you've been on
this journey for a while now you have
been activists and leaders uh for for
some time and I'm wondering if in the
span of that time you've noticed any
differences in the way that you've been
able to engage uh or the impact that
your voice has made and I know you did a
little bit speak to this but was there
anything specific that you've noticed
has has changed since you started
so I mean being in for me at least being
an active activists mean means reacting
to the times you're living in and
Changing Times being present and I
constantly change my ways and try to
highlight new issues when it happens
something in our world that didn't
happen a week ago you know that that is
new because we know that what happens in
the world around us in society in one
way or another happens to us
so the covet pandemic and as one example
where I needed to like change my
activism in order to reach people you
know we created
um campaigns digitally and and movements
digital digitally instead to reach
people and at least in my part of the
world and the war in Ukraine has changed
what I talk about when I talk about
activism when I talk about climate
advocacy and we talk about the
connections between War and Peace and
democracy and climate change and nature
changes more often now and and we talk
about fossil fuel dependency how it's
important that we move away from fossil
fuel dependency in order to create peace
to not be reliant on dictatorships so
that's just examples of things that are
happening in recent years that has kind
of changed the way I do activism and
what I highlights in my work
thank you Penelope
um that was a great example of
practically what that looks like
um
for you and I appreciate you sharing
that
um Kyle I think I noticed you pop up
earlier did you have something you
wanted to add
um the thing that's always difficult for
me because I'm a bit of a ludite is I
have to like keep up on Which social
media platforms and like how best to
communicate with the people I'm trying
to reach um because like a lot of the
times when I'll be working with UNICEF
for the icdf they'll be like oh just
like let's let's post something to like
forbes.com and like let's engage youth
there and I'll I'll have to be like like
no that's not what we're using like
let's start a tick tock right now and
see if we can reach people that way
um so that's something I always have to
keep up on and change
thank you
um I'm not sure if our other speakers
had anything they wanted to add
um yeah I would just like to add
something I think for me personally I've
learned more about my audience and the
changes that have had I've learned more
about my audience and the changes that
they experience I think especially in
the Caribbean the leadership has always
been traditionally top down with youth
participation may not be always
meaningful or long term and I think
along with that I've realized that as
activists and Advocates we can only
reach so much due to this huge knowledge
Gap and this made me really realize the
importance for education and
encouragement
understanding how we are uniquely
affected and how we are contributors yet
victims and I think really understanding
that has played a major role in how I've
tweaked my activism as Penelope was
seeing adjusted my own advocacy to reach
my audience and young people here
understanding how we're affected by
natural disasters flooding and what we
can do in order to mitigate and adapt
thank you Priyanka and I think your
answers have also helped conceptualize
you know what exactly activism can look
like uh you know across the board um
which is great I am conscious of the
time so I think I'd like to take one
question from the audience before
passing over to Kyle Pruitt to close so
we have a question from Paul Stevenson
um which is what guidance or experiences
to the panel have for strategies that
help to sustain their movements or
spaces
um and Paul clarifies that this could
include sustaining momentum and
motivation as much as funding and
resourcing
I can take over
um so you you said it really well Paul
there like funding funding is really
vital for our movements uh and moreover
funding that doesn't alter the movement
right because sometimes we're
conditioned to uh the ideas that we can
present uh in in our movements through
to the funding and again what I would
say again in the momentum part would be
Children and Youth Advocates need to
understand that they're making a
difference right so trying to engage
them in very meaningful ways and seeing
how they make that impact is going to
keep momentum up also mentorship I know
that it's very important and I talked
about it in in my speech as well uh to
have somebody who has been through uh
different
um different experiences and can mentor
uh the movement without diminishing the
light of each person that puts uh uh who
contain who is part of the movement and
I would also say that it's import
important to to be mindful of the mental
health of children and of Youth
Advocates I know that I was ready to do
absolutely everything uh for the
movement and that meant a lot of burnout
and not having the tools to navigate
spaces and so I would see a lot of
children being pushed to their limits by
by activism and by adults who didn't
really know how to how to approach this
right so make sure that when you're
engaging children uh and to keep this
momentum up you you gave them you give
them the space to also rest to also play
to also enjoy childhood so that's that's
from my part
thank you Dominique
um would any of the other panelists like
to add to that
no fantastic
um in which case calpert I will hand it
over to you thank you very much everyone
thank you Aditi I'm sorry to say this
wonderful conversation which in my view
is just beginning is has to come to
close because we've run out of time a
few final thoughts one about the concept
of resilience which Dominican others
have talked about in my own view as a
child psychiatrist I have seen
resilience massively misused it is not
an individual trait of a child in fact
that can be so politicized that if it is
an individual trait then why should
governments do anything to help children
who are vulnerable resilience is a is a
is a property of an environment not just
simply the child that's in it but the
the state around it the people that love
that child and protect it as well so
let's not be simple-minded when we come
to talk about resilience in our panel
obviously is way ahead of many of us and
understanding that I would like to
conclude our comments with an invitation
to think together about how ECP C could
use such a work youth working group to
move forward
their passion their competence and their
ability to to Really provoke us to conf
to talk about the right things makes
perfect sense follow us on the ecpc
newsletter our second
the third lecture in this series will
feature Sherry Weston who's the
president of Sesame Workshop and Dr Hiro
yoshikawa who will be talking about a
variety of interventions that have been
phenomenally successful in in migratory
and
um
and refugee camps around the world thank
you for being with us thank you to the
panel what a contribution they have made
to us today thank you
[Music]